et tu achètes et il m'aimait beaucoup et
puis il est rentré chez lui
[applaudissements]
parfois ils ont aussi des relations sexuelles
se déplacer sur un bloc sur une chaise
changé de vie
tous les soucis supprimés
[musique]
des prix
Russie
Aujourd'hui
nos soldats
notre Ukraine, nous pouvons dormir, nous pouvons
Aujourd'hui, les enfants se sont réveillés et peignent les plus petits
nos guerriers et les guerriers dans les tranchées sont
les pirogues sont même souvent petites
des enfants sur les murs, je crois qu'il faut les aider
plus de charges lunaires, encore des combats d'oies
sinon un homme
couper
russe
tanks à l'école tu es étranger
bien joué
il y a des enfants ici
pleuré merveilleusement
les gars sauvages ont bien sûr pleuré
les a emballés
et bien sûr
de notre aide
ça aide vraiment
[applaudissements]
[musique]
Les Russes ont attaqué l'Ukraine
j'avais l'air
15h
qu'avons-nous
trains lettre Z
nager sans eau
Maman, d'accord, je trouverai l'école moi-même aujourd'hui.
nourriture Elle a dit que la guerre avait commencé et
effrayant a dit que la Russie avait attaqué et
tout est anxiété
Peut être
une fusée a survolé l'épi
son patron est contre son travail
centrale électrique pour récupérer de l'énergie
Mère
Je suis arrivée au village avant ma grand-mère, j'ai ressenti la même chose
ton
la nuit, je pensais que tu étais juste une blague
l'émotion s'est avérée fausse, j'ai juste agi
[musique]
J'essaye sans, c'est dégueulasse
Pacha abandonne le spectacle pour le vin
peut-être deux options
F3
Bien que non, ce sera la même situation, d'accord
Le flux est toujours une récompense et est exécuté sous contrôle
après avoir torturé, il y aura des colas
considéré comme un jeu tellement cool, alors je
J'adore 6 roubles, n'est-ce pas
Donc
peux-tu me donner un pas pour travailler
[applaudissements]
verre
Loboda
je dois aller au Shell en deuxième
Masséna
bavardé
Et maintenant nous le sommes quand nous parlons
C'est pourquoi
[musique]